Good Morning, John.
Actually, you know what, it's not a good morning.
It's a bad morning,
because I am freaking tired of getting
dicked around by customer service.
The customer service industry is, it seems, engaging in
a practice that I will henceforth be calling an
Asshole Propagation Program.
I am defining these APPs as any societal program that
ignores kindness and openness and coolness,
and rewards general douchebaggery.
As an example so you can better understand what an APP is
I am going to reenact a recent call that I had
with a customer service agent of a company
that I give my business to that I will
not mention the name of.
APP Hank: Hi, this is Jeffrey from a big company's
APP department.
Hank: Hi, yeah, my name's Hank Green.
My credit card was recently defrauded
and so I had to cancel my card and
I didn't realize that it was the card that
I had listed for your company's service on automatic
payment and  I just got a letter from you guys
saying that you were charging me an extra thirty bucks
because, uh, the payment didn't go through,
but it was just 'cause my card was defrauded and
I was too busy to try and find all of the places
where it was listed as the automatic payment option and
so I thought maybe that wasn't a necessary charge.
APP Hank: Yeah, it's perfectly legal for us to do that.
Hank: Well, yeah, I wasn't saying that
it's not legal for you to do it,
I just thought that since none of the other half a
dozen companies  that had that card listed as
an automatic payment option, didn't charge me
anything, that it was maybe a little silly
for your company to charge me all that money.
APP Hank: I apologize sir, but that's our policy.
Hank: Um, yeah.
But,  do you see where I'm coming from here?
Like, it's just, like, is your company going
to charge me a bunch of money
every time they're legally allowed to do it, even if, you
know, I'm already dealing with a bunch of crap?
APP Hank: Well I'm sorry sir but there's nothing I
can do for you. Um, that's just our policy.
That's, that's how we do it.
And now, my friends, the moment you have been
waiting for: the moment when I give in to the APP.
I am not proud.
I'm ashamed.
But I did.
Hank: This is bull-(beep)!
First I have to deal with all the bullcrap because
I got my credit card defrauded
and that guy was stealing money from me,
and now your company decides
that they can steal more money from me because
I already got money stolen from me!
This is not okay!
What you're doing is just making me as like an -
(beep)-hole and say lots of curse words like
bull-(beep) and (beep)-hole so that you can have
a justification for going to your manager
and asking me for my money back!
So just go do it!
Go ask for me, my, my, freaking money back and I will
stop yelling at you because I am not a mean guy!
I am a nice guy and I am tired of this!
I hate that you made me yell at you!
Go talk to your manager!
APP Hank: Sir, will you please hold?
Hank: Yes! I will hold!
APP Hank: Sir, we've gone ahead and credited
the thirty dollars back to your account.
Is there anything else I can do for you today?
Hank: No! That is all you can do for me!
Thank you. Bye.
So I just wanna send out a message to all of the
Asshole Propagation Programs in the world.
We've got our eye on you.
What you're doing might decrease your costs for now,
but in the long run, all you are doing is creating
more assholes, and it's not just customer service,
it's every societal program that punishes
kindness and rewards douchebaggery.
All of you! It needs to STOP.
Do not give in!
End the APPs!
Viva la revolution!
I just wanted to show you that this is-
I don't have one of these.
It's just a flash drive with duct tape on it.
And that part's been in my ear.